oh god that's scary
Cisco my gosh is so good
getting ready for know filtered Hey
we're prepping baby boo beep boop
someone's getting married but that one's
on their period that's appetite I just
want you guys to see what mamrie got
sent to the hotel in my name relatable
penis the flava phoenix we start walking
uh-huh it's like yeah it's like huh so
we start walking it's like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm so good I slay their
actual words in the show look here's
okay yeah sure get it up with into your
diving our shoes sister shoes please
move oh just some spoilers with Jack and
Dean uh how you feel all right yeah
you've never looked better
my face is very clean yeah Jack how do
you feel feel right yeah yeah I feel
right all right yeah a sec secret
project
hashtag darker no integrity not shiny
funny hashtag that's like so funny
Jacobi there we go
and instantly into the pre-prep right
before we leave for a very first oh very
exciting Amy made us shirts
I'm the charge by a horse one I'm the
eldest one
I'm the with my blonde nope brunette one
yeah
okay okay we're about to go in for our
first London show my hands are shaking
actually is exciting we just don't know
how our humor will do in a different
cultural setting my heart's oh okay
we're about to find out babes hmm yep
exactly
okay
finished our first night of no filter
show I'm a little drunk
maimry went downstairs to get food which
is why I felt comfortable filming myself
being a little drunk
morning after a first show excited very
tired this rough mamrie ate lasagna that
fell on the floor last night that's a
desperate because okay in his night two
of no filter yay prep here's um yeah
you've seen this room before Riya oh
this is what we didn't show you last
night these wonderful humans gave us
these flasks that I don't see it that
you have quotes no putable I can see it
mmm sort of there you go and there's it
says that's a lot of pee you're a lot of
Pete Camp Takota
and they gave each one of us a flask
that has a different quote on it from
what we said in the movie and I was just
really [ __ ] sweet oh so we're hot
little Mexican dolls I'm cute changed I
just my very British very British looks
just like you meant it there's a
pre-emptive show pre-show hey someone in
a beer I'm drunk
oh god I spilled on her crotch
mamrie spill like Scott it's rigged okay
I've got my number-one fan here didn't
care visits so we're done
I love it so [ __ ] charming
ah to Dublin we go
it's the pre time before very last show
yeah memories doing her pre-show ritual
showing us photos of beans very good
today I did a great prank right in that
my camera yeah we we sincerely think
that this theater is haunted I mean
there's do you the one in your eye do
you know what I think the bullet project
I hate it um so that we got we are
culture today with just like beautiful
flanked by art is what this theater used
to be called
my hand
okay this mine just got back from the
dublin nofilter show which was so
amazing humans of dublin and surrounding
towns that have come to Dublin you were
all so wonderful thank you so much for
enjoying this stupid that we are just
like vomiting on you who I had to go I'm
a little um gotta go
yes very Europe Barry now
you
this is a great night
hmm